everybody don't worry ignite winning
that violation business congratulations
to Jim McMahon winning this incredible
result in the olden by-election he stood
on a campaign of jobs of people's needs
opposing what Tory austerity is about
but also bringing investment
apprenticeships and a good future the
people of old them Jim an experienced
council leader brilliant local man can
speak up for the people of this town
speak up in Parliament for them and
bring about the kind of decent
prosperous opportunity future that we
want for everybody everybody in this
country congratulations Jim McMahon MP
listen this is a truly overwhelming
thing for a local lad to represent the
town he loves in Westminster is a big
big issue and I'm very clear I am sick
to death for what the Torah to do two
towns like all them the whole northern
powerhouse rhetoric is nothing more than
a write-off of the north to create a
poorhouse and I'm sick of it and I think
it's about time we show the Tories that
people have had enough thank you
jeremy corbyn a strong our party is not
just here in oldham but all over the
country it shows the way we've driven
the Tories back on tax credits on police
cuts on their whole austerity agenda and
narrative it shows just how strong how
deep rooted and have broad our party the
Labour Party is for the whole of Britain
thank you very much everybody